und jetzt ist mir achim wiese der
sprecher der dlrg live zugeschaltet
guten tag herr wiese gründe wir haben
gerade das tragische rettungs drama
gesehen an der ostsee ist es denn
wirklich typisch dass es an der ostsee
so starke strömungen gibt das kinder und
auch der mann so mitgerissen werden
zunächst einmal sind unsere gedanken
natürlich bei der familie des vaters
dort ums leben gekommen ist natürlich ja
es gibt an der ostsee durchaus
gefährliche strände die ihnen genau
ähnliches vorweisen wieder oder ganz
froh diese diese wellenbrecher oder an
diesen bann brechen entstehen bei
entsprechenden witterungsverhältnissen
also bei winden beispielsweise ein
student entsprechend gefährliche
strömungen und aus diesem grunde sind
auch diese stellen immer eins nicht
badestelle gekennzeichnet und eben wie
wir jetzt praktisch erlebt haben auch
leider lebensgefährlich oft denkt man ja
auch wenn wasser flach ist man noch
stehen kann dass es dann automatisch
ungefährlich ist woran erkennt man dann
gefährliche gewässer generell also die
gewisse werden sie sehr schwer erkennen
ob die gefährlich sind oder nicht wenn
man strömung sieht man nicht das heißt
sie müssen einfach auf die starken
signale der dlrg achten zb war das dann
als hob auch die gelbe flagge
signalisiert oder ist die dann bedeutet
es ist gefährlich für kinder und
nichtschwimmer die rote flotte
beispielsweise signalisiert lebensgefahr
und das könnte man auch gleich setzen
mit badeverbot
leider stellen wir immer wieder fest
dass die menschen zu leichtsinnig sind
und diese signale schlichtweg missachten
was raten sie denn persönlich allen
eltern wiener muss man am kind dran sein
reicht es das kind ja auch sagen wir mal
fünf meter entfernung im blick zu halten
nein das reicht keineswegs bei kindern
insbesondere kleinen kindern heißt es
und das ist auch der der wirklich
wichtige appell an alle die jetzt
zuschauen wenn ich mit meinem kind oder
meinen kindern ins oder ans wasser hier
immer so dicht am kind zu sein dass sich
jeder zahlt dann ich betone jederzeit
zugriff
denn wenn auch mein kind nur ansatzweise
gerät in gefahr zu in gefahr zu geraten
danke schön achim wiese von der dlrg